Vaccines are celebrated
for their part in fighting disease.
But, a growing group of people
seem to believe that they endanger
our health, instead of protecting it.
The Internet is full of stories
about allergic reactions,
the onset of disabilities,
and even death following
vaccination appointments.
And, it's true vaccines can have side effects.
Let's look at how they work,
and how dangerous they really are.
Your immune system is a
complex army of billions of cells.
Soldiers,
intelligence cells,
and weapons factories.
Every day, you're attacked countless times,
but your immune soldiers alone
usually deal with that,
so you don't even notice.
If an infection becomes serious though,
our intelligence cells gather
intel about the attackers
and activate our weapons factories.
You know the weapon: antibodies.
They're like targeted missiles produced
specifically to combat the invader.
Unfortunately, this process takes
several days to complete.
That gives intruders
a lot of time to do damage.
Contrary to popular wisdom,
what doesn't kill you doesn't make you stronger.
Our bodies really don't want
to fight serious wars over and over,
so our immune system came up
with an ingenious way
to get stronger and stronger over time.
If we fight an enemy that is dangerous
enough to trigger our heavy weapons,
our immune system automatically
creates memory cells.
Memory cells remain in our body
for years, in a deep sleep.
They do nothing but remember.
When an enemy attacks for a second time,
the slumbering memory cells awaken,
and order coordinated attacks
and the production of antibodies.
This is so fast and effective,
that many infections you beat once
will never make you sick again.
You might even be immune
against them forever.
Which is also why little kids are constantly ill;
they don't have enough memory cells yet.
And this beautiful natural mechanism
is what we build on when we use vaccines.
How Vaccines Work
As great as memory cells are,
obtaining them through an infection
is unpleasant and sometimes dangerous.
Vaccines are a way of tricking
our bodies into making memory cells,
and becoming immune to a disease.
They pretend to be a dangerous infection.
One way of doing this is to inject
invaders that can't do harm.
For example, by killing them,
or by ripping them into pieces.
Our immune systems deal with
these kinds of vaccines pretty easily.
Sometimes, it's necessary to make
our immune system work harder though,
to produce even more memory cells.
Live vaccines are the real deal.
An enemy that can punch back is
a bigger challenge than a dead one.
But this also sounds like
a sort-of horrible idea.
What if the germs win?
To avoid that, we breed a sort-of
weak cousin of the real germ in the lab.
Just powerful enough to annoy the immune
system, and create enough memory cells.
Okay, so these are the basic
principles of vaccine use.
They provoke a natural reaction in our bodies
that makes us become immune
against very dangerous diseases.
Some, like the flu virus, mutate so often
that we need a new vaccine every year,
but most vaccines protect us
for years, or even a lifetime.
But, there's a catch.
Like everything in life,
vaccines have another side:
Side effects.
What are they, and what happens
if your child develops one?
The Risks of Vaccines
It's complicated to directly compare the side
effects of vaccines with the effects of diseases.
For example,
hundreds of millions of people are
vaccinated against measles in the West,
but there were only 83,000
cases in Europe in 2018.
So, with numbers that different,
even mild side effects can seem scary
compared to the bad effects of a disease
that we don't see as much anymore.
Before the measles vaccine
became available in 1963,
virtually every single child on Earth
contracted measles at some point.
An estimated 135 million cases in the 1950s.
Every single year.
But are measles really that
dangerous in the year 2019?
With our advanced healthcare
and new technologies,
are they worth the risk of vaccine side effects?
Let's do a thought experiment
based on real numbers.
Imagine a developed country
in a parallel world.
It has good healthcare but
people stop vaccinating.
In this scenario, let's say ten
million children caught measles.
What happens?
Nine million eight hundred thousand, or 98%,
will get a high fever and a very unpleasant rash.
Up to 800,000 of them, or 8%,
will suffer from dangerous diarrhea.
700,000, or 7%, will suffer from an ear infection,
which can lead to permanent hearing loss.
600,000 kids, or 6%, will suffer from pneumonia
-- the most dangerous effect of measles.
It, alone, will kill 12,000 children.
Up to 10,000 children, or 0.1%,
will get encephalitis.
2,500 kids, or 0.025%, will contract SSPE,
a disease where the measles
virus lingers in their brain
and kills them a few years later.
Taken together,
around 2.5 million children will suffer from
somewhat serious effects from measles.
And, about 20,000 children
will be killed by measles.
It doesn't stop here though.
The kids who beat measles are left with
a severely damaged immune system
that needs a lot of time to regenerate.
Time for other diseases to do further damage.
Aside from that, what's almost guaranteed
is that your kids will have a really
bad time for about two weeks.
Okay, but what about vaccines?
It's only fair to look at these risks, too.
So, let's repeat our thought experiment.
But, this time, we vaccinate ten
million children with MMR.
What would theoretically happen here?
After being vaccinated,
of our 10 million kids,
around ten percent get a fever.
500,000, or 5%, will get a mild rash.
Up to 100, or 0.001%,
might have a serious allergic reaction
and will have to be treated.
Up to ten boys, or 0.0001%,
might get inflammation of the genitalia.
And up to ten kids in total, or 0.0001%,
might get the most serious
side effect: encephalitis.
So, we vaccinated ten million kids.
In total, around one hundred and twenty had
side effects that were somewhat serious.
Thanks to good medical treatment in developed
regions, almost all of them will be fine.
What about autism?
The connection of autism and vaccines
stems from one source
that has been disproven countless times.
We'll link to further reading
and videos in the description.
But, in 2019, it's fair to say that
vaccines do not cause autism.
All right, but what about deaths?
It's really hard to say if even a single one of
our 10 million vaccinated kids would die.
We really did look hard and
talked to a lot of different experts.
If we ignore self-reporting,
we could only come up with a tiny
handful of documented cases
for all the hundreds of millions of children
who received the MMR vaccine since 1971.
Measles are many, many thousands of
times more dangerous for your child
than even the absolute worst
case of vaccine side effects.
You have to search for lethal vaccine side
effects with a huge magnifying glass
and, even then, it's very hard
to find confirmed cases.
While, deaths from measles
are real and easy to find.
In 2017 alone, 110,000 people
died from measles worldwide.
Statistically, today,
300 children will die of measles.
One since this video started.
You can compare vaccines to seatbelts.
Are there weird freak accidents where
someone gets killed by their seatbelt?
Well, yes.
But, do you personally think it's safer
to not put a seatbelt on your kid?
Wait a second!
What if your kid is actually allergic?
What if none of the things we've said
applies to your specific situation?
In this case, you need to become the
greatest vaccination promoter of all.
Because if your children can't be vaccinated,
only the collective can protect them.
This is called herd immunity,
and it's the only thing that
can protect your unvaccinated child.
Herd immunity means that enough
people are immune to a disease,
that it can't spread, and dies
before it reaches its victims.
But to accomplish this for measles alone,
95% of the people around you
need to be vaccinated.
Conclusion
The problem with the debate about vaccines
is that it's not fought on a level playing field.
While the pro-vaccine side argues
with studies and statistics,
the arguments against them are
usually a wild mixture of gut feeling,
anecdotes, and misinformation.
And feelings are often immune to facts.
We'll not convince anybody
by screaming at them.
But we can't hide from the reality
of what anti-vaccine conspiracies do.
They kill babies too young to be vaccinated.
They kill healthy children that are just unlucky.
They bring serious diseases back
from the verge of extinction.
And, the biggest side effect
of vaccines is fewer dead children.
Vaccines are one of
the most powerful tools we have
to eradicate the monsters that
most of us have already forgotten.
Let's not bring the beasts back!
Vaccines are celebrated
for their part in fighting disease.
But, a growing group of people
seem to believe that they endanger
our health, instead of protecting it.
The Internet is full of stories
about allergic reactions,
the onset of disabilities,
and even death following
vaccination appointments.
And, it's true vaccines can have side effects.
Let's look at how they work,
and how dangerous they really are.
Your immune system is a
complex army of billions of cells.
Soldiers,
intelligence cells,
and weapons factories.
Every day, you're attacked countless times,
but your immune soldiers alone
usually deal with that,
so you don't even notice.
If an infection becomes serious though,
our intelligence cells gather
intel about the attackers
and activate our weapons factories.
You know the weapon: antibodies.
They're like targeted missiles produced
specifically to combat the invader.
Unfortunately, this process takes
several days to complete.
That gives intruders
a lot of time to do damage.
Contrary to popular wisdom,
what doesn't kill you doesn't make you stronger.
Our bodies really don't want
to fight serious wars over and over,
so our immune system came up
with an ingenious way
to get stronger and stronger over time.
If we fight an enemy that is dangerous
enough to trigger our heavy weapons,
our immune system automatically
creates memory cells.
Memory cells remain in our body
for years, in a deep sleep.
They do nothing but remember.
When an enemy attacks for a second time,
the slumbering memory cells awaken,
and order coordinated attacks
and the production of antibodies.
This is so fast and effective,
that many infections you beat once
will never make you sick again.
You might even be immune
against them forever.
Which is also why little kids are constantly ill;
they don't have enough memory cells yet.
And this beautiful natural mechanism
is what we build on when we use vaccines.
How Vaccines Work
As great as memory cells are,
obtaining them through an infection
is unpleasant and sometimes dangerous.
Vaccines are a way of tricking
our bodies into making memory cells,
and becoming immune to a disease.
They pretend to be a dangerous infection.
One way of doing this is to inject
invaders that can't do harm.
For example, by killing them,
or by ripping them into pieces.
Our immune systems deal with
these kinds of vaccines pretty easily.
Sometimes, it's necessary to make
our immune system work harder though,
to produce even more memory cells.
Live vaccines are the real deal.
An enemy that can punch back is
a bigger challenge than a dead one.
But this also sounds like
a sort-of horrible idea.
What if the germs win?
To avoid that, we breed a sort-of
weak cousin of the real germ in the lab.
Just powerful enough to annoy the immune
system, and create enough memory cells.
Okay, so these are the basic
principles of vaccine use.
They provoke a natural reaction in our bodies
that makes us become immune
against very dangerous diseases.
Some, like the flu virus, mutate so often
that we need a new vaccine every year,
but most vaccines protect us
for years, or even a lifetime.
But, there's a catch.
Like everything in life,
vaccines have another side:
Side effects.
What are they, and what happens
if your child develops one?
The Risks of Vaccines
It's complicated to directly compare the side
effects of vaccines with the effects of diseases.
For example,
hundreds of millions of people are
vaccinated against measles in the West,
but there were only 83,000
cases in Europe in 2018.
So, with numbers that different,
even mild side effects can seem scary
compared to the bad effects of a disease
that we don't see as much anymore.
Before the measles vaccine
became available in 1963,
virtually every single child on Earth
contracted measles at some point.
An estimated 135 million cases in the 1950s.
Every single year.
But are measles really that
dangerous in the year 2019?
With our advanced healthcare
and new technologies,
are they worth the risk of vaccine side effects?
Let's do a thought experiment
based on real numbers.
Imagine a developed country
in a parallel world.
It has good healthcare but
people stop vaccinating.
In this scenario, let's say ten
million children caught measles.
What happens?
Nine million eight hundred thousand, or 98%,
will get a high fever and a very unpleasant rash.
Up to 800,000 of them, or 8%,
will suffer from dangerous diarrhea.
700,000, or 7%, will suffer from an ear infection,
which can lead to permanent hearing loss.
600,000 kids, or 6%, will suffer from pneumonia
-- the most dangerous effect of measles.
It, alone, will kill 12,000 children.
Up to 10,000 children, or 0.1%,
will get encephalitis.
2,500 kids, or 0.025%, will contract SSPE,
a disease where the measles
virus lingers in their brain
and kills them a few years later.
Taken together,
around 2.5 million children will suffer from
somewhat serious effects from measles.
And, about 20,000 children
will be killed by measles.
It doesn't stop here though.
The kids who beat measles are left with
a severely damaged immune system
that needs a lot of time to regenerate.
Time for other diseases to do further damage.
Aside from that, what's almost guaranteed
is that your kids will have a really
bad time for about two weeks.
Okay, but what about vaccines?
It's only fair to look at these risks, too.
So, let's repeat our thought experiment.
But, this time, we vaccinate ten
million children with MMR.
What would theoretically happen here?
After being vaccinated,
of our 10 million kids,
around ten percent get a fever.
500,000, or 5%, will get a mild rash.
Up to 100, or 0.001%,
might have a serious allergic reaction
and will have to be treated.
Up to ten boys, or 0.0001%,
might get inflammation of the genitalia.
And up to ten kids in total, or 0.0001%,
might get the most serious
side effect: encephalitis.
So, we vaccinated ten million kids.
In total, around one hundred and twenty had
side effects that were somewhat serious.
Thanks to good medical treatment in developed
regions, almost all of them will be fine.
What about autism?
The connection of autism and vaccines
stems from one source
that has been disproven countless times.
We'll link to further reading
and videos in the description.
But, in 2019, it's fair to say that
vaccines do not cause autism.
All right, but what about deaths?
It's really hard to say if even a single one of
our 10 million vaccinated kids would die.
We really did look hard and
talked to a lot of different experts.
If we ignore self-reporting,
we could only come up with a tiny
handful of documented cases
for all the hundreds of millions of children
who received the MMR vaccine since 1971.
Measles are many, many thousands of
times more dangerous for your child
than even the absolute worst
case of vaccine side effects.
You have to search for lethal vaccine side
effects with a huge magnifying glass
and, even then, it's very hard
to find confirmed cases.
While, deaths from measles
are real and easy to find.
In 2017 alone, 110,000 people
died from measles worldwide.
Statistically, today,
300 children will die of measles.
One since this video started.
You can compare vaccines to seatbelts.
Are there weird freak accidents where
someone gets killed by their seatbelt?
Well, yes.
But, do you personally think it's safer
to not put a seatbelt on your kid?
Wait a second!
What if your kid is actually allergic?
What if none of the things we've said
applies to your specific situation?
In this case, you need to become the
greatest vaccination promoter of all.
Because if your children can't be vaccinated,
only the collective can protect them.
This is called herd immunity,
and it's the only thing that
can protect your unvaccinated child.
Herd immunity means that enough
people are immune to a disease,
that it can't spread, and dies
before it reaches its victims.
But to accomplish this for measles alone,
95% of the people around you
need to be vaccinated.
Conclusion
The problem with the debate about vaccines
is that it's not fought on a level playing field.
While the pro-vaccine side argues
with studies and statistics,
the arguments against them are
usually a wild mixture of gut feeling,
anecdotes, and misinformation.
And feelings are often immune to facts.
We'll not convince anybody
by screaming at them.
But we can't hide from the reality
of what anti-vaccine conspiracies do.
They kill babies too young to be vaccinated.
They kill healthy children that are just unlucky.
They bring serious diseases back
from the verge of extinction.
And, the biggest side effect
of vaccines is fewer dead children.
Vaccines are one of
the most powerful tools we have
to eradicate the monsters that
most of us have already forgotten.
Let's not bring the beasts back!
​